hey everybody how's it going I'm Rob and
welcome to my tutorial on how to solve a
5x5 rubik's cube professor at this point
before proceeding I highly recommend
that you know how to solve both the
regular 3x3 Rubik's cube and also the
4x4 Rubik's cube revenge before
attempting to solve the 5x5 professor I
will be referring to both my 3x3 and 4x4
tutorials both of which can be located
on my channel playlists now there is
only one new algorithm that we're going
to have to learn in order to solve the
5x5
as long as you know all the algorithms
to solve the 3x3 and 4x4 cubes and the
new algorithm to solve the 5x5 is
relatively short solving the 5x5
is very similar to solving the 4x4 as
far as placing the center's and also
pairing up the edge pieces however once
you have done so on the 5x5 cube and
corrected all the parity errors that
occur with the edges there are no
additional parity errors that occur when
solving the rest of the cube so to save
some time I'm not going to go over a
notation for the 5x5 cube since it is
exactly the same as the 4x4 cube the
middle layer on the 5x5 cube is never
turned by itself in any of the
algorithms instead we are only going to
be turning the inside layers like that
and also the inside and outside layers
together like we did in the 4x4 cube and
also the outside layers by themselves as
well so now I'd like to go over the
component pieces of the 5x5 cube ok so
as you'll notice the center block on
each side of the cube is composed of
nine pieces arranged as a 3x3 block just
as in the 3x3 cube the 5x5 has one fixed
center piece on each side which never
moves and that designates the color of
the entire face there are three
different types of central pieces there
is that one middle center piece there
are four edge or side Center pieces per
side and there are also four corner
Center pieces as well every side of the
cube also has 12 edges which make up
what are called triple edge pieces or
treasures every Treach piece is composed
of what I like to call a middle edge
piece and also two
outer edge pieces just as in all cubes
there are also each corner pieces on the
entire cube just like the 4x4 we must
first place the center pieces then pair
up the edge pieces and fix parity and
then solve the cube as a 3x3 now let's
go on to placing the centers on a mixed
up 5x5 all right so what we're going to
do first is to pick a bottom color and a
top color and solve those centers first
I choose white from my bottom and yellow
from my top and I always solve the white
Center first to do that we're going to
need to form 2x1 blocks like this one
we're going to instead of joining two of
them like we did in the 4x4 we're going
to join three of them to form a 2x3
block we are then going to join a three
by one block to that to complete the
center so let me show you what I mean in
this cube I have already formed three
2x1 blocks so if I wanted to join this
one to this one they need to be vertical
this one is in the bottom two layers of
this three by three and this is also so
we could join that up and then we would
join this one to that to form a 2x3
and then finally join a three by one
block to that to complete the center so
that's just an example now let's go into
detail on how to do that in order to do
that we need to first form a 2x1 block
on the white side to do that we must
first join an edge Center piece to this
middle Center piece so you look around
the cube for an edge Center piece that
is white and it has to be in the middle
layer here it has to be either in this
position or this position to join it to
this Center if it was up here you could
not join it so it's in this position so
we can flip it directly up next to this
one so now we have formed our first 2x1
block now we want to form another one
and as we're going to do that you're
going to notice that we're going to be
joining mostly corner pieces that corner
center pieces with edge Center pieces so
we have another 2x1 block already solved
for us here so if we hold this white
Center
on the top face and we get this
positioned on the front face we could
join them up this is in the bottom two
layers of the of the top Center so we
need to get these two in the bottom
layers as well so here is it's in the
bottom layers if you flipped it around
like this this is in the top left of
this 3x3 block so we couldn't join it
like that so we get it in the bottom
right and now we can flip it directly up
to form a 2x2 white block so now we want
to get one more 2x1 block here so that
we form a 2x3 so we look around the cube
when you have two pieces on the same
face like this it's quite easy to join
these two pieces up all you have to do
is basically hold it so that one is on
the top and one is here on the bottom
then what we could do is we basically
lift this piece up to the top face bring
it down so that because we want it here
so we have to get it in this position so
we bring it down and then we just bring
it back so now we have formed a 2x1
block by doing that so let me do that
real quick again so it's here if you
want to bring it up flip it down and
then bring it back so now we have
another 2x1 block so if we want to get
it next to here this one is in the top
left of this 3x3 block so we have to get
an empty spot in the top left of this
block so if we twist it like that now
you'll see we could join this piece up
to that we couldn't put it like that
because it wouldn't join so we have to
get that spot like that
now we could shift this piece up to the
top and form a 2x3 block so now we want
to get that 3 by 1 white block in here
so we have to jump we have to form that
first okay so we have a piece here and
here and the other one is here the white
Center is on the other side over here so
what we want to do we could do that same
move that we did to join those two
pieces in this case it is in the top
right so we bring this piece up shift it
down so that now it's in the correct
position for joining it to this piece
and then we bring those both faces back
down so now we have formed a 2x1 however
we need to form a three by one so we
need to join this piece up to that as
you'll see this empty spot is in the
bottom left and so is this piece here so
we could flip this directly up when we
do that you'll see we that we mess up
the center so we have to shift this back
in order to do that once we have joined
this up we have to get it out of the way
so that we could bring this face back
down so you don't want any of these
pieces to still be in this face so now
we could join that back down now you'll
see this is on the right side and these
two are on the left so all we have to do
is basically turn this 180 degrees and
we have formed the first Center so now
we want to form the opposite center
which is yellow so we do the same thing
we have a piece here that is a side
middle piece aside center piece and it's
in the middle layer so we can flip it
directly up but as you'll notice you'll
mess up the center so once you get it up
you get it out of the way so that no
more yellow pieces are in this face you
turn it like that and then you basically
flip it back down to resolve the center
so that's one 2x1 block here is another
one as you'll notice these two pieces
are in the bottom two layers of this 3x3
block so we have to get these two pieces
in the bottom as well so you wouldn't
flip it like that because you couldn't
join it like that so you get it so that
it is positioned in the bottom right
like that
and now you could flip it up and when
you do that you're going to mess up the
center so we flip it up get it out of
the way so that no yellow pieces are in
this face and then we flip it back down
so we have that and now we have a 2x2
yellow block so now we want to form
another 2x1 yellow block and get it next
to this 2x2 so we already have a 2x1
yellow block here so it's in the upper
left of this 3 by 3 so we have to get an
empty spot in the upper left
so now you'll see we could flip this
directly up next to that we could also
if you wanted to if this piece was here
in the bottom right we could also get it
so that this piece is in the bottom
right as well and then you can flip it
up so once we flip it up you'll notice
you're going to mess up the center so we
flip it up and now we used to put this
layer back down so we don't want any
yellow pieces in that layer because
it'll just bring it back down so we flip
it up and then we get it out of the way
so now this layer is completely cleared
so now we can bring it back down and we
have the white center resolved and we
have a 2 by 3 block of yellow so now we
want to form the 3 by 1 to get it in
there so as you'll see white is on the
right and yellow is on the left so we
can basically we don't have to worry
about messing up any of these centers
yet okay so we have a corner center
piece here and we have an edge center
piece this one's in the bottom layer so
we get this one in the bottom layer now
we can flip it up and we form the two by
one block so now we have to look for the
last piece which is here this piece is
in the bottom-left but this empty spot
is in the top-left so we basically just
flip this up and now we could flip that
up and form the three by one okay so now
we have to join this piece up here we
can't just flip it like that because
it'll mess up the center's so we
basically get this piece turn it 180
degrees around and we kick this piece
out by flipping it up turn the top 180
and then bring it back down that's a
similar move to the one done in the 4x4
tutorial and if you did all that step
all the steps correctly you should have
two completed centers so now you're
ready to move on to the second part of
the center's